Let DesignaKnit quickly space
your button holes for you.
Let's start with a basic cardigan sweater.
Switch to Original Pattern Drafting.
Select one of the front pieces
and zoom in on that front piece.
We want the first button hole, one
inch from the neck opening, and
there will be a total of six buttons.
I'm turning on my numbering, so we have
a point of reference to talk about here.
Make sure that your rulers
are set to dimensions.
In my case, inches.
Set the zero orientation to point number
six at the very edge of my neck opening.
Now I'm going to add my
top button one inch down.
I'll turn on the hairline cursor
to make things a little easier.
Select the plus symbol or the add tool
and place the point for the first button.
Right now you're looking
at the lower corner.
You can see that it's a little
difficult to place this exactly.
I guess I could zoom in and
add point 7 but let's peek at
the table and be more accurate.
Click >piece >table and you can
see that point number seven is not
exactly one inch down or in line.
So let's make it minus one and zero.
Guess what?
There are only two more steps to
position the other five buttons.
Click >alter >equal parts,
and click on the lower line
between points seven and eight.
When prompted, enter five for the
five remaining buttons and click okay.
Voila.
We have six evenly spaced
marks for our buttons.
Let's confirm that.
We'll use our measure tool and we'll find
out how many rows are between our buttons.
Change the rulers to stitches and rows.
This time, measure between 0.7 and eight.
Remember, we always measure clockwise
around the piece with this tool.
So DesignaKnit calculated
32 rows between my buttons.
Well, this works if you're adding
a vertical band or a facing to your
sweater, but what if you're picking
up and knitting a band horizontally?
Simply rotate the piece.
Click alter, rotate clockwise 90 degrees.
Now we can see that at my gauge
there are 20 stitches between the
buttons and you can easily calculate
your button holes accordingly.